[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
vaniel hablando en el estudio de daniela
que tales actor está no le provocó un
poquito quedé con hambre con más hambre
danny problemas de economía vamos a eeuu
porque buscan poner en regla a las
aerolíneas que está pasando y todo
porque por la pandemia y es que la
pandemia pasaron muchas cosas sobre todo
el sector aeronáutico quedó muy afectado
no claro que si tuvieron enormes
pérdidas y ahora se están desquitando
porque los ticket lucrado en empresas
muy altos pues mire las quejas de los
consumidores presentadas ante el
departamento de transporte aumentaron
casi siete veces en 2020 con respecto al
año anterior como era de esperarse y de
ese total nueve de cada diez personas
pedían reembolsos por los tiquetes que
no pudieron utilizar mientras estaban
confinados pues actualmente las
aerolíneas están obligadas a ofrecerle
reembolsos más no bonos de viaje no es
lo mismo a los pasajeros cuyos vuelos se
cancelen o cambien significativamente
sin embargo nunca se ha definido
estrictamente cuáles son esos criterios
para definir si hay un retraso o no
ahora el departamento dirigido por
pitbull
coja comentario es un proyecto para
establecer esos límites que el límite se
establece esta propuesta bueno entonces
le voy a dar ejemplos primero si la hora
de salida o de llegada cambia tres horas
o más para un vuelo nacional o al menos
seis horas para un vuelo internacional
también cuando se cambie el aeropuerto
de salida o de llegada del pasajero o
cuando se agreguen paradas o se causen
de degradaciones significativas en la
experiencia de viaje al cambiar el tipo
de avión inclusive aplicaría para
pasajeros que utilicen tarifas
económicas que son las preferidas desde
luego por los usuarios
este proyecto entonces estarán 90 días
en comentarios y cuba- comprará dólares
a un cambio 5 veces mayor a la tasa
oficial porque el gobierno decidió hacer
esto más medidas económicas en cuba como
las que hemos visto a lo largo de esta
semana la tasa de cambio oficial hoy es
de 24 pesos y en el mercado informal es
de 115 pesos este último es el preferido
por los residentes de la isla la
presidenta del banco central marta
wilson gonzález
yo que el sistema bancario estableció
una nueva tasa de 120 pesos por dólar
pero solamente para la compra a los
ciudadanos de las pequeñas empresas esta
es una estrategia que busca socavar el
mercado informal y capturar esas
reservas de divisas tan escasas en este
país y el objetivo final es reanudar el
cambio de divisas que se suspendió en la
pandemia porque simplemente no había
efectivo ahora raúl entre los
beneficiados según expertos miren qué
interesante podrían estar los turistas
porque ellos vienen cambiando sus
dólares al tipo oficial o sea 24 pesos
cubanos en los hoteles y después salen a
la calle y descubren que los podían
vender mucho más caros en el mercado
informal 115 dólares ahora les van a dar
en 115 pesos ahora les van a dar 120 eso
pasa venezuela antes de que se utilizará
la coneau pasa en argentina también
exactamente y la onu como lo hizo en su
momento el presidente de obeid en le
lanzó un regaño a las petroleras
bueno pues primero el fondo monetario
internacional hizo también su propio
regaño les dimos los gobiernos no les
entreguen subsidios
a las empresas de energía porque esto va
a desincentivar el ahorro y
adicionalmente la onu también es un
llamado de atención a las petroleras
diciendo se están enriqueciendo a costa
de los más pobres veamos el informe
en una conferencia de prensa el
secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres acusó a las empresas de
petróleo y gas por obtener sus ganancias
a costa de los más pobres según él una
actitud inmoral
hago un llamado a todos los gobiernos
para que graben las ganancias excesivas
y usen esos fondos para apoyar a los más
vulnerables en estos tiempos difíciles e
insto a las personas de todo el mundo a
enviar un mensaje claro a la industria
del combustible y sus financistas esta
avaricia ridícula castiga a los más
pobres y vulnerables mientras destruye
nuestro único hogar común el planeta
mientras que la inflación ha afectado
las finanzas de los hogares a nivel
global desde el comienzo de la guerra en
ucrania según la onu las ganancias de
las grandes hidrocarburíferas ascienden
a los 100 mil millones de dólares sólo
en el primer trimestre del 2022 al mismo
tiempo
345 millones de personas están en riesgo
de la inseguridad alimentaria gravar los
beneficios de los gigantes del gas y del
petróleo una opción que francia ve con
buenos ojos el miércoles fue aprobado un
proyecto de ley de poder adquisitivo una
bonificación de 30 céntimos por litro de
combustible frente a los 18 céntimos
anteriores una medida destinada a ayudar
a los hogares en dificultad según el
gobierno la ley también prevé un aumento
del 4 por ciento de las pensiones de
jubilación y varios mínimos sociales
otra medida es la triplicación del bono
macrón en el cual las empresas estarán
eximida de pagar impuestos hasta finales
del 2023
daniela cómo se mueven los mercados
hablemos de los indicadores económicos
bueno esto es inusual que hablemos de
américa latina porque por lo general a
esta hora se han cerrado los mercados
pero comencemos con argentina porque
inicia un nuevo día bursátil pero en las
tres jornadas anteriores el índice
principal de la bolsa de buenos aires ha
subido casi un 7% movido por la posición
del nuevo superministro de economía
ahora si nos vamos para los mercados
asiáticos en donde el nerviosismo ha
disminuido relativamente después de la
visita de nancy pelosi a la isla de
taiwán y hoy cerraron con ganancias
siguiendo un wall street han fortalecido
las ganancias también se replican en
europa siguiendo los datos económicos
positivos en eeuu y también gracias a
las utilidades trimestrales de algunas
compañías no todas quienes trae como
cifra el día bueno a usted le gusta el
cine o no amo el cine yo no soy tan así
de cine usted no sabe que a mí no me
gustan todos no le gusta nada pues mira
las cifras son los 90 millones de
dólares que costó la producción que tuvo
la película vaquero de warner bros que
ya había sido rodada protagonista era
leslie grace la estrella de in the
heights esto esto es un movimiento muy
inusual casi inédito para hollywood pues
ya que la película no va a ver la luz
pues warner consideró que no me decía ni
un debut ni en cines ni en su plataforma
de streaming veomac la empresa citó un
cambio de estrategia tras su fusión con
el grupo discovery lo cierto es que
quedó descontento en el ambiente tanto
para actores como para directores
también para aficionados pues yo no soy
muy experta en el tema one pupiales
probablemente era toda una cátedra aquí
del tema pero son 90 millones de dólares
claro los cinco accionistas exactos los
que invirtieron en esa película de 90
millones de dólares puedes perderlo así
de la nada para votarlos a la basura a
la basura daniela menos mal que usted no
le gusta el cine no sufre tanto sí señor
gracias a mí como siempre mañana nos
vemos con más economía pasamos